today on campaign track we're looking at
the labor manifesto and here's what
Jeremy Corbyn says about it they're
going to tell you that everything in
this manifesto is impossible that it's
too much for you because they do not
want real change in this country but is
this manifesto really impossible let's
get beyond the rhetoric and look at the
numbers and to put it in context this
bar shows you the size of their spending
plans last time around in 2017 the
longer that is the more money's being
promised and back then labor was
planning to spend 49 billion pounds by
the end of the five-year Parliament have
a look at this this time around
they've gone way further with nearly 83
billion pounds of spending some of it
goes on education scrapping tuition fees
a good chunk on Health and Social Care
but how will they actually pay for it
the short answer is a lot of taxes labor
say higher income tax for top earners
that's going to raise 5.4 billion pounds
a year but let's dig into that there's
something actually interesting going on
here
in theory these taxes should be raising
eleven point four billion pounds but
Labor's predicting behavioral changes so
people working less moving abroad and so
on it's a reality it actually only
raises half of that while they're also
raising corporation tax a lot they think
businesses won't react in the same way
which is a little bit odd though in
labor cements they have at least
provided they're working so you've got
higher income taxes on top earners 14
billion pounds from higher capital gains
tax at a dividend tax - all told it's a
big levy on investment income what
though about that windfall tax on oil
and gas companies I was mentioned at the
manifesto launch how much is that kind
of raise well we don't know because it
seems to have been added so late it
doesn't actually appear in the manifesto
anyway this is all current taxing and
spending day to day stuff but it's only
the beginning labor have also announced
two huge investment funds worth 250
billion 150 billion to pay for a whole
host of infrastructure projects on top
of that you've got all those
nationalizations water rail companies
mail and so on how much are they going
to cost the answer says labour is
nothing because the government will be
paying for an asset so it won't add to
the national balance sheet then again in
the small forest the manifesto they did
say there was a chance it cost some
money but they hoped not when you take
it all together certainly it is a
radical program the big
current spending increase in peacetime
according to the IFS and actually
contrary to what mr. Corbyn said I'm not
going to tell you this is impossible
it's ambitious but it's very possible
but it's also very very expensive